speaking of comic books venom the
classic Marvel comic book character
venom is moving to Philadelphia I can
think of no better place for venom to go
having been born and raised in
Philadelphia venom is going to make his
headquarters now in Philadelphia really
have all played the City of Brotherly
Love
that's right the editor for venom comics
apparently is a llama Drexel University
in Philadelphia and he's decided that
all the school of wizardry Philadelphia
needs its own superhero New York has him
LA has him he wants Philadelphia to have
a hero so Flash Thompson
aka venom is moving to Philadelphia and
in the air this one's been I'm a [ __ ]
hero man does anyone remember the
creation of this character who's like
I'll wait you're [ __ ] with the
symbiote that that was bad but Flash
Thompson is trying to make him good yeah
easy where's venom so we can walk cuz
he's all [ __ ] up but his legs you know
right yeah I still like again what part
of [ __ ] like I'm gonna eat your [ __ ]
he killed people yes but now he's like
I'm gonna eat your cheese dick it's a
much nicer kinder venom hey Ralph I
thought there was another superhero from
Philadelphia oh I forgot the gay ghost
also from Philadelphia don't get all
cocky because one girl says your voice
makes her come alright
slam in my hometown with the gay ghost
jokes why can you know that there's
another superhero from Philadelphia to
James Garmin boom boom Shakalaka Gord
man is cute dude jets for Baskin it for
a minute gore man what's your powers
enormous balls fault my I cannot I had
knockout a villain with my balls
enormous balls is not a power it's go
really
a bloody me with my testicle with great
balls come great responsibility oh yeah
that's an infinite capacity for alcohol
- like a camel for [ __ ] liquor
exactly
[Music]
you